public details about what U.S officials
described as the object discovered over
Northeastern Alaska remains sparse the
Pentagon says it was about the size of a
car unmanned and did not appear to be
maneuverable this was traveling at about
40 000 feet which posed a potential a
reasonable threat to civilian air
traffic and the decision was made to
take it down the decision came from
President Biden as he was preparing to
meet with Brazil's president at the
White House Biden had been criticized by
Republicans for waiting days to shoot
down a Chinese spy balloon as it
traveled across the United States last
week the administration had feared the
risk of a bad landing and so waited
until the balloon was over the Atlantic
Ocean to take it down U.S officials say
there's no indication the object shot
down over Alaska on Friday was related
we do not know who owns it whether it's
a whether it's state owned or or
corporate owned or privately owned we
just don't know the U.S Northern command
is now working to recover the object
that landed on ice near the Arctic
Circle as the American public waits to
learn what it was Heidi Joe Castro Al
Jazeera Washington